Alright guys, so here is the last example for the ICT Silver Bullet. So as you can see, I'm at 950 or 55 fish and I can see this clear buy side liquidity here. And you can see if we take out this liquidity here, we can look for lower prices. We can anticipate that price is going to go lower. So we have the liquidity here. Let's go back to the one minute timeframe and look for a clear market structure shift.
have another bicep liquid you sweep here right and let's see how this plays out
okay perfect so you can see we have a higher high high low higher high here and
that is like the prime market such a shift where you have like this tiny
structure broken right here so now what we do have is a very tiny free
relief app and also this volume imbalance kind of volume imbalance remember that
topic. Yeah. So we don't want to talk we don't want to take like volume imbalance into consideration.
This is very really gap. So now that would be our entry point and let's go short right there,
put our stop at the high here. That is 1.82 handles totally opposite from what ICT says.
And let's go for one to two and let's see how this plays out. We have our entry at 1044. So remember
no entry after 1050. So let's see how this plays out. And price goes ahead and hits our
take profit. If price broke this structure right here before coming back to the entry then that
would be a very very low probability setup. Because we are not looking for internal market structure.
Sorry external market structure but we were looking for a break off internal market structure
something like that. Okay. Fractal Marcus Chokter Shift. We do not want to look for a huge
Marcus Chokter Shift like this one. I hope that clears everything about ICT silver bullet.
Essentially I'm going to repeat this rule again. Identify Liquidy Sweep, right? Mark out
um, liquidity that has not been swept yet,
uh, market structure shift on one minute and entry.
Yeah. So this right here is our, uh,
liquidity level that is yet to be swept.
Okay. So we also have this liquidity sweep right here.
If we go out of market structure shift somewhere around here,
we would have taken our entry and we could have targeted these levels here,
which is like liquidity, resting liquidity here.
So let's say if we got our marker such a shift here, that would be my target essentially, but I would only go for one to two regardless of
My like liquidity level. I would not target this if my one to two was hit
So essentially you can see if I held the trade here you can see the price took out this liquidity level right here
And let's see how where the price goes and
Yes, it reversed right after taking out this
this liquidy here and also this actually it did not take out this level here
it just took out this structure here and then boom so that was it guys
re-wash this video again and again and practice this again and again and you're
gonna learn this tragedy and you're gonna master this tragedy I'll see you guys in
the next one